foreign
[Applause]
are powered up versions of regular
attacks that can only be used while in
Rage status
they often give Fighters new combo
opportunities or extend their combos
raise driving dead he's dead this
mechanic was introduced in Tekken 7 but
will eventually be replaced by heat
Smash in the upcoming Tekken 8.
in this video let's take a look at the
top 5 characters that have the best rage
drives in Tekken 7.
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
nice
[Music]
what's up what do you think do you agree
with this list
[Music]
make sure to comment below and don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]
thanks for watching be sure to leave a
like And subscribe also huge shout out
to our patreon supporters if you want to
further support this Channel and making
more content like these please visit the
link to our patreon page below the
description
[Music]
foreign